brent is a guy with a lot of passions
and correct but heavy-metal music might
be at the top of his list Wow
when he's not swinging with his wife
he's at heavy metal shows that's how you
like to spend your free time love it he
formed a heavy metal band with some of
the guys from the office Oh Brent even
started meeting with this woman who
teaches one-on-one coaching he's taking
his music career very seriously I told
you you'd like this Michael Chris
whiling recorded the session with Brent
and his music teacher and here we go
right now here they are do this right
okay now do this beep mmm don't you feel
like that sound is emanating from above
your hand from right here right behind
your eyes right
[Music]
oh very good that was good I'm getting a
tone oh I do the Emperor's Gopal
Oh
why well that is some session I was
gonna say or is he trying to learn to
sing or do sound of it it sounds like
that slaughtering of the Lambs so Brent
I would like to play your new song with
your band that is an original song what
is this song about most of all it's
called fight the fight what is this
about this is about this is about
fighting the fight when you know you're
right so it's original music well there
it is fight the fight everyone is
probably now excited fucking-a your
drums I say thank God for the year of
vocal training because imagine if you
had tried that without vocal trainer
would have found about